اذا فقط ننوه اننا نشاهد صورا مباشره من
مخيم بلاطه لوصول سيارات
الاسعاف حيث جرت هذه العمليه عمليه قصف
واستهداف لمركبه
وهذا الموقع الذي
نتابعه جرى فيه استهداف كما قلنا لمركبه
في شارع القدس شرقيه مدينه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه
وانباء عن استشهاد مجموعه من الفلسطينيين
في البدايه منعت قوات الاحتلال طواقم
الاسعاف من الوصول الى المركبه والى
الشهداء
يبدو ان سيارات الاسعاف وصلت الان لكن
بالنظر الى ما افادنا به
ليث مراسلنا من نابلس كان قد اشار الى
وصول المركبات كما نتابع في هذا الصور
التي كانت قبل قليل وصول المركبات قبل
سيارات الاسعاف اذا الى السياره التي تم
استهدافها ليث اذا نعود اليك ليث جعار
مراسل
الجزيره اذا اذا ليث الان يستمع الينا
ونحن نتابع سيارات الاسعاف ليث ضعنا في
تطورات
المشهد نعم بدا بالف الانسحاب لجيش
الاحتلال من محيط مخيم بلاطه بعد عمليه
عسكريه استمر ل عده ساعات هنا تحديدا حيث
نتواجد في هذه اللحظات مكان استهداف
المركبه الفلسطينيه التي ايه يعني كان
يتواجد بها عدد من الشهداء تم استهدافها
عبر مسيره لجيش الاحتلال ما ادى الى
اشتعال النيران بها بشكل كبير بعد ذلك منع
الاحتلال طواقم الاسعاف
وا الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول الى هذه
المنطقه وا نقل اي اصابه قوات الاحتلال
حاصرت المركبه من كافه المحاور وبعد ذلك
قاموا بمصادره جثامين من تواجد داخل هذه
المركبه
وبالفعل بدا يعني قبل لحظات قليله فقط
الانسحاب من مخيم بلاطه بعد عمليه عسكريه
واشتباكات تواصلت لعده ساعات هنا نرقب
حاله الطواقم الطبيه التي تبحث في هذا
المكان وبين الركام على يعني ما يشير الى
من كان بداخل هذه المركبه قوات الاحتلال
على ما يبدو انها صادرت ايضا المركبه
وضعت التراب على يعني مكان او في مكان
تواجد هذه المركبه وانفجار هذه المركبه
هنا نرصد لربما في هذه الصوره حيث الطواقم
الطبيه وطواقم الاسعاف والهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني تعمل على البحث عن يعني اي شيء
او اي جزء يوصل الى من تواجد في هذه
المركبه قوات الاحتلال استمرت في حصار
مخيم بلاطه واشتباكات تواصلت لعده ساعات
على وقع هذه العمليه انفجارات عده وا
يعني حاصر الاحتلال ودفع بال التعزيزات
العسكريه من حاجز بيت فوريك حاجز عورتا
ووصولا الى مدينه نابلس حيث حاصر المنطقه
الشرقيه ودفع بال التعزيزات العسكريه
اسرائيليه خلال ساعات الليل يعني
الانفجارات والاشتباكات لم
تتوقف النتيجه لهذا الاقتحام هنا يعني
نشاهد الطواقم او احد عناصر طواقم الهلال
الاحمر والطواقم الطبيه واعمال التمشيط
والبحث عن اي من محتويات هؤلاء الشبان
الذين تواجدوا داخل هذه المركه والذين تم
استهدافهم عبر طائره مسج الذين نعم الذين
تم هويه كامل واستهداف متواصل او تواصل في
كافه انحاء المدينه اثناء م جريمه الاحمر
الوصول الى الاصابات تم استهدافهم واطلاق
النار عليهم بشكل مباشر من قبل قوات
الاحتلال لمنعهم من الوصول الى المركبه
ونقل اي اصابه من احتلال بشعه الذي